the question about whether how to think
about artificial intelligence and
personhood and right start official
intelligence I think is really
interesting it's been teed up I think in
two particularly good films AI which I
really like but many people don't it was
a Stanley Kubrick film Steven Spielberg
took over laid in the process and then X
Mac and I more recently which think most
people it was a quite a good film and I
actually used these when I teach courses
on the subject we asked the question are
the robots in these films are they
persons yes or no one possibility as you
say a necessary condition for being a
person as being a human being so many
people are attracted to that argument
and say only persons can be only humans
can be persons right all persons are
humans now maybe not be that all humans
or persons but all persons are humans
well there's a problem with that and
this is put most forcefully by the
philosopher Peter Singer the
bioethicists singer who says to reject a
species possibility that the species has
rights and not to be a patient for moral
consideration the kind of things that
have moral consideration on the basis of
the mere fact that they're not a member
of your species he says is equivalent
morally to rejecting giving rights or
moral consideration to someone on the
basis of their race so he says
speciesism equals racism right and the
argument is imagine that you encountered
someone who is just like you in every
possible respect but it turned out they
actually were not a member of the human
species they were Martian let's say or
they were a robot right and truly
exactly like you why would you be
justified in giving them less moral
regard so people who believe in capacity
exfuze
have to at least be open to the
possibility that artificial intelligence
could have the relevant capacities Albia
Tevan they're no they're not human and
therefore qualify for personhood on the
other side of the continuum one of the
implications is that you might have
members of the human species that dart
persons and so Annika phallic children
children with born with very little
above the brainstem in terms of the
brain structure are often given in his
example they're clearly members of the
human species but their abilities to
have the kinds of capacities most people
think
are relatively few and far between so
you get into this uncomfortable position
where you might be forced to recognize
that some humans are non persons and
some nonhumans are persons right now
again if you take a bite the bullet and
say I'm willing to be a speciesist being
a member of the human species is either
necessary or sufficient for being a
person you avoid this problem entirely
but if not you at least have to be open
to the possibility that artificial
intelligence in particular may at one
point become personal like and have the
rights of persons and I think that that
scares a lot of people but in reality to
me when you look at the course of human
history and look how willy-nilly we were
in declaring some people non persons
from the law slaves in this country for
example it seems to me a little humility
and a little openness to this idea may
not be the worst thing in the world
you